مسار في موسكو يخترق جهود العلاقات
التركيه السوريه اجتمع في العاصمه الروسيه
يوم الاربعاء وزراء دفاع روسيا وتركيا
وسوريا ورؤساء استخبارات الدول الثلاث
بحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه نقشت في
الاجتماع غير المسبوق منذ سنوات سبل حل
الازمه السوريه ومشكله اللاجئين وجهود
محاربه الجماعات المتطرفه في سوريا
بالنسبه للجانب التركي فانخراط انقره في
الملف السوري متعدد الاوجه فمن ناحيه هناك
ملف لاجئين السوريين بكل تعقيداته وهناك
من ناحيه اخرى الاشتباك التركي مع مسلحي
الاكراد في الشمال السوري الذي يبقى
الهادسا الدفاعيه المسيطره على التمثيل
التركي في اجتماع موسكو
هدفنا الوحيد هو محاربه الارهاب وتحييد
التنظيمات الارهابيه لحزب العمال
الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
وتنظيم الدوله نبذل جهود لمنع المزيد من
حركات اللجوء من سوريا الى تركيا كما
اكدنا على ضروره حل المساله السوريه
بطريقه شامله في اطار قرارات مجلس الامن
عقب الاجتماع قالت مصادر تركيه للجزيره ان
وزراء الدفاع الثلاثه اتفقوا على تشكيل
لجنه المشتركه تضم ممثلين دفاعين
واستخباراتين وتبدا اجتماعاتها نهايه
يناير المقبل في موسكو ثم تتوالى
الاجتماعات في انقره ودمشق بحث الاجتماع
وفق المصادر التركيه فتح الطرق الدوليه
والسماحه للبضائع التركيه بالمرور عبر
الاراضي السوريه كما بحث تصورا يضع حدا
لوجود ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
شمال سوريا واتفق على اليه مشتركه لتسهيل
عوده اللاجئين السوريين بعد توفير ارضيه
مناسبه تقول تركيا ان النظ سوريا يرغب
بهذه العوده جاء هذا في تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه مولود شاو شغله الذي شدد على ان
تتم بشكل ايجابي مع ضمان سلامه اللاجئين
العائدين واشار الاجتماع اولي مرتقب مع
نظيره الروسي والسوري يعد خارطه طريق قبل
الترتيب لاجتماع رؤساء الدول الثلاث
سلامه اللاجئين السوريين اكد عليها لاحقا
وزير الدفاع التركي خلص
مشددا على عدم اقدام بلاده على اي عمل
يكون من شانه المساس بهم او بالسوريين
داخل تركيا او سوريا
على مهل تسير خطوات التطبيع بين انقر
ودمشق وهي تاتي عقبه تصريحات تمهيديه
سابقه من المسؤولين الاتراك كان الابرزها
حديث الرئيس التركي قبل اسبوعين عن اليه
ثلاثيه لتسريع المسار الدبلوماسيه بين
بلاده والجانب السوري